the reunification come up did
humanitarian issues come up in the
meeting yes it did and one of the things
I will tell you that I'm most happy
about and that as you know is a big
sticking point is bringing back the
remains of thousands of soldiers that
were killed this came up last minute
this wasn't this was sort of last minute
you know would it be possible because I
get letters all the time from families
who lost a son lost a brother lost a
father in Korea that was a rough fight
right and they were buried along the
roadways they were buried as you know
soldiers go back and forth into battle
and they were burying them along
roadways and they same please please
could you do it I get so many letters
from people who lost a loved one in in
North Korea essentially in North Korea
right and I would say I'm gonna try and
I brought it up and I'll tell you what
it was almost immediate now in the past
it was you couldn't even talk about it
but it was really a nice response how
quickly did you talk about a trip to the
United States did you talk about I think
at the right time he'll be absolutely be
coming to the White House yeah look
we've been very it's been a very intense
relationship it's been short and very
intense and of course before that it was
pretty rhetorical it was you know not a
pretty thing people were very worried
but without that I don't think we would
have been here today he wants to get
something done I want to get something
done I think we'll get it done and we
started off by really a very strong
document I think people are surprised to
see it they're shocked
and then add some more things that we
got after that was signed mm-hmm and so
it can you give us maybe a glimpse into
what you keep sort of referring a little
bit to things that will be coming that's
so I just think that we are now going to
start the process of Dien nuclearization
of North Korea
I believe that he's going back and was
started virtually immediately and he's
already indicated that and you look at
what he's done so we got our hostages
back but they've blown up one of their
sites one of their testing sites their
primary testing site in fact some people
say they're only testing site they're
getting rid of a missile which isn't in
the document that was done afterwards
they're getting rid of a missile testing
site they're doing so much now so it's a
process and it's it's really moving
rapidly last question because I know you
have a lot to do obviously he wants
something on his end certainly wants the
the world community once sanctions
lifted he wants economic opportunity in
his people needed desperately there are
people starving there so I guess the
question is the order what would he have
to do to get the sanctions lifted to get
the Economic Opportunity opened up for
the people well when he wants his
security and I understand that and he'll
get that and he wants to see if they can
make that incredible location because
it's incredible it's between China and
South Korea think of it I'm in the
real-estate business think of that
little location is that you have China
and you have South Korea he's got right
in the middle of both of them surrounded
by water okay
those that's called like power there be
anything better than that and it's also
beautiful land it's a credible land so I
think he wants I just think he
understands that I told him about that
today and I think he really understands
it and the Chinese wants to make it
clear involved South Koreans the
Japanese so I think look China can't be
thrilled about a very strong group of
people having nuclear missiles with
great capability right next to him so I
really do believe they are they were
very very helpful I think maybe a little
bit less so in the last two or three
months because we were talking about
trade and other things and you know it's
nothing's gonna interfere with my
relationship with President Xi because I
have great respect for him he's really a
great man and the true sense he's
exposed to what are the best stories you
tell and it's an interesting story
historically speaking is you were having
dessert with him it's right at
mar-a-lago chocolate cake
do you remember and I said this was the
furnace was after Assad had used
chemical weapons on his own people
that's right and you had launched the
first strike and you I said mr.
president and we just sent 58 missiles
into Syria to hit a certain target and
he said please say it again with his
interpreter I said we just sent 58
missiles and by the way to show you the
technology every single one of those
missiles from 700 miles away in the
ocean ships mission every 158 missiles
50 it hits it's incredible technology
what what we have is so incredible so
lethal not that we want to do it but so
lethal but that was done because Syria
Assad used chemical gases on children
and we had to do that had President
Obama gone over the red line I think you
maybe would have had a different story
in the Middle East I really believe that
but he didn't do that but we did and so
I told him sitting at mar-a-lago at
dinner eating chocolate cake I said
either he's gonna leave or or whether to
still be friends but he didn't leave but
he understood he really understood he
really doesn't want to see me well he I
think yeah I think he really did because
he knew that a lot of people and a lot
of children were killed by gas and he
yeah he fully understood I know you have
a lot to do mr. president thanks for
being generous with your time thank
congratulations thank you very much
appreciate it